frente a esta cocina improvisada a los
argentinos se agolpan para conseguir una
comida gratis en argentina el precio de
los alimentos ha subido un 20% en solo
tres meses así que en los barrios
obreros las ayudas estatales ya no son
suficientes para alimentarse en nuestra
sociedad respecto de los ingresos y hay
una inflación muy alta sobre los
alimentos y entonces bueno está
comprobado que en quien tiene poquitos
ingresos lo usa mayoritariamente en
comer la inflación se dispara en todo el
mundo impulsada por la guerra en ucrania
y por el confinamiento de las ciudades
chinas que ponen apuro a las fábricas y
elevan los costes de producción en eeuu
a la inflación aumentó un 66 a lo largo
del año pero los hogares estadounidenses
no se están apretando el cinturón por
todo eso el gasto de los consumidores
aumentó un 27 por ciento en este
trimestre ayudado por el aumento de los
salarios en francia la inflación está en
su nivel más alto desde 1985 alcanzando
el 48 por ciento interanual los precios
de la energía subieron un 26 6%
en el surtidor de gasolina los
automóviles notan la diferencia
188 es un poco caro por litro
él dice la aumenta incesantemente no
sabemos a qué santo alabar hacerse rico
el poder adquisitivo estuvo en el centro
de la campaña presidencial en francia en
manuel macro me prometió un paquete de
medidas sociales para el verano para
ayudar a las familias más pobres y
evitar cualquier nuevo movimiento social